all right broadcasting right now from
beautiful Daytona Beach because I got to
tell you my job is pretty hard I have to
come to places like Daytona Beach and
and and be here and I was trying to
explain this to my wife yesterday I was
telling her that you know it's it's I
said to her I mean you yeah I you have
to stay back and watch all three kids by
yourself but I have to go to the beach
I mean yuck it's it's I I envy you
personally I I wouldn't want to be doing
this but uh but I have to I mean I got
to make sacrifices for the family honey
don't you understand that but I am
making this enormous sacrifice because
I'm giving a talk at embry-riddle
Aeronautical University where I'll be
giving a lecture on aerospace
engineering actually won't be on that
subject although would be pretty
hilarious if I tried to try if I tried
to if I attempted a lecture on that it
is a free event though I can tell you
that and because let's be honest nobody
in their right mind would pay to see me
so it's a free event and it's open to
the public so I hope that that you'll
come out if you're in town now a lot to
cover today starting with the of course
devastating events of yesterday but an
event that I hope will spur positive
change and I want to talk about what
that positive change possibly could be
but before we get into that I have to
tell you about helix sleep okay listen
they they and I'm being serious here
this is they they sent me one of these
helix mattresses and I can attest from
experience now as a longtime insomniac
as someone who has counted billions of
sheep in my day this thing will put you
to sleep if it if it put me to sleep
then it will put you to sleep for sure
and if you listen to my show at the same
time then you'll really go to sleep but
you won't even need that because the the
mattress somehow manages to basically
give you exactly what you needed caters
to whatever your needs happen to be no
matter if you're a you know a side
sleeper you sleep on your back or your
stomach if you get really hot when you
sleep if you like you know soft or firm
bed whatever it is with helix there's
just no confusion and there's no
compromising and it's not complicated
okay all you got to do is you go helix
sleep they have a quiz
that I took myself and it only took like
2 minutes to complete and what it does
is it matches your body type and your
sleep preferences and it figures out a
mattress that works for you so it does
all the hard work for you
helix sleep is rated the number one
mattress by GQ and Wired magazine and
CNN called it the most comfortable
mattress they've ever slept on I could
attest to that myself just go to helix
sleep calm / Walsh take their two
minutes sleep quiz and they'll match you
with a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life and
for couples helix can even split the
mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they won't do
anything about the fact that your wife
always steals the covers and then
accuses you of stealing them if you try
to snuggle under just a little piece of
the cover
if so you don't freeze to death in the
middle of the night you can't do
anything about that but the rest it
takes care of they have a 10-year
warranty and you get to try it out for a
hundred nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will love it so you don't have
to worry about that
helix is offering up $225 off all
mattress orders for any listeners right
now it's 125 dollars off if you got a
helix sleep comm / Walsh
that's helix sleep comm / Walsh for up
to 125 dollars off your mattress helix
sleep comm / Walsh okay starting with
unfortunately the bad stuff Notre Dame
Cathedral as you no doubt heard was on
fire yesterday in Paris the first day of
Holy Week a day after Palm Sunday and
this happens it's a building that went
under construction almost 900 years ago
took well over a hundred years to
construct not counting all the
renovations throughout the centuries so
this is just the man-hours that went
into this including the the renovations
that it's just you know it's it's it's
really beyond comprehension it is and
still is one of the greatest churches
ever to be built in the world anywhere
in the world in history and the sad fact
is that a sizable chunk of it has gone
forever now because of what appears to
be an accidental fire probably related
to some of the construction that was
being done to fix to renovate you know
some of the things with the church a
sizable chunk of it is gone but not all
and miraculously and I do mean that
literally the bones are still standing
many of the Magnificent stained-glass
windows are still intact
the two main towers of the church are
still there so it's gonna be hundreds of
millions maybe billions of dollars to
repair / rebuild but it hasn't been
reduced to ash it's it's still there
which is a testament to many things
including the architectural prowess of
the Middle Ages
what building today could withstand
could survive an inferno like that not
many of them I'll tell you that but
ultimately it's a it's a testament to to
God of course but here's what I want to
dwell on for a moment people if you
watch yesterday and I was watching them
don't watch cable news a lot these days
but for something like this I turned it
on I was watching the coverage and and
by the way I'll give credit where it's
due
sideout CNN did a great job of covering
the the fire cuomo whatever heat
whatever time he's i turned on CNN or
whatever time it was seven o'clock eight
o'clock and he did the whole show on on
the cathedral burning and i actually
watched the entire thing I thought he
did a just did a really wonderful job so
I'm you know I don't don't usually give
credit to CNN I'll give him credit there
but if you're watching the the footage
you see people crying in the streets
they're distraught over it well why is
that you know well I would say because
the cathedral is beautiful right and
when something beautiful is made and
then destroyed we recognize it as a real
loss
nobody would cry if they demolished the
parking garage down the street right but
they do cry over this because one is
beautiful and one is not and beauty is
important it's not a small thing you
need beauty in faith and you need it in
life because beauty speaks to the
fundamental longing of the human soul
and
churches should strive always to satisfy
that longing not not just with the
building obviously it's more than the
building with the building as part of it
the building should be part of it every
aspect of the church experience
including the building itself should be
a part of this effort to point people
towards God to speak to that to that
longing that we have for beauty
you know I've I've told the story before
about when my wife and I once walked
into a mall in Kentucky only to realize
that it was not a mall because it was
actually a mega church I think I told
that I think I told the story on Ben's
on the on a Sunday special the building
looked in every way like a mall and when
I wrote this today there are people say
well how could you have possibly made
that mistake I'm telling you the
building looked exactly like I mean I
would defy you if you looked at this
building I would define and you didn't
know what it was I would defy you to
think anything other than mall I mean it
looked a hundred percent like a mall and
there was from what we could see there
was nothing on the building there was no
religious paraphernalia that we didn't
even see anything that said the word
Church on it obviously we saw that that
we would have figured it out so it
looked like a ball among we walked in
and once inside the structure we began
to realize our mistake but it only
really fully dawned on me when a woman
you know in a neon green t-shirt walked
up to up to us and handed us a program
and then we realized oh okay now I see
what's going on here and then I found
out later that this church was built
right where a mall once stood I mean it
used to be a mall actually literally
which I guess is part of the confusion
for us because it was obviously in a
mall like area with restaurants and
stuff all around and a big parking lot
and people were walking in and out and
just looked like a mall but it wasn't
and I thought about that incident
yesterday as I watched the Notre Dame
Cathedral burn because nobody would ever
make that mistake with the notre-dame
Cathedral or a building like it you look
at that building and you know why it's
there it is there
- - is constructed to worship and
glorify God and to help in the
facilitation of that worship to even
look at the building is to even now
after the fire to look at it is to have
a religious experience because its
beauty brings your mind unwittingly to
higher things you can't help but think
of God when you look at that building it
focuses your sights upward both
physically and spiritually because it is
beautiful and that's what beautiful
things do now not every church can look
like that I know that and maybe no
church ever again will even notre-dame
may never again look exactly like that
and that's just terrible to think about
but churches are still being built in
this country and lots of money is being
spent on building them so this excuse
that I hear from people that well we
want to spend the money on helping the
poor instead oh please stop it you know
just just stop it
that mega church that I walked into I
guarantee that thing costs millions of
dollars to build millions any church
costs money to build and a lot of modern
churches are very very very expensive
mega churches are very expensive ok so
it's not like this well you know we're
gonna tamp down the beauty so we can
spend the rest on the poor no that's not
what they're doing ok
they're tamping down the beauty because
they don't want it and they also want to
spend more on fancy light displays and
audio-visual stuff and all that kind of
stuff so it's not like we stop making
beautiful churches to cut costs and give
it to the poor and even if that even if
that was the excuse even if that was
true I would still disagree with it and
Jesus disagreed with it - he rebuked
that attitude remember when the woman
was anointing Jesus with the expensive
oils and perfumes and Judas is the one
who said well we could sell that stuff
and give it to the poor we should be
doing that instead and and Jesus rebuked
Judas and said you're always going to
have the poor with you the point there
is to to take something to spend money
yes and energy and time on glorifying
God is a is a good thing and it's a
false choice anyway you don't have to
choose between glorifying God and beauty
and art and all of that and helping the
poor you can do both and in fact you do
help the poor with beauty the poor are
people too and I'm talking about this is
a beauty is a fundamental human need
that everyone no matter what your
socioeconomic status is shares that need
but we don't even have that excuse
because we are investing money in our
churches into the buildings and they
could be made beautiful not Notre Dame
Cathedral level beautiful yes but
beautiful yet they are not and it's not
that we're nowadays you know trying to
make beautiful churches and failing okay
that would be that would be maybe one
thing because it's the thought that
counts I guess but what makes it so
insidious is that we're trying really
hard to make unbeautiful bland ugly
profane churches and we're succeeding
our houses of worship look like shopping
malls and prisons and basketball
stadiums on purpose that's an aesthetic
choice that's being made
so whereas Notre Dame stands out
gloriously amid the skyline modern
churches are meant to sort of blend in
like chameleons or like the you know the
shy kid at the homecoming dance who's
kind of trying to blend into the
surroundings no one looks at I mean that
and that's what churches do when you
look at modern churches it's like
they're embarrassed to be a church they
don't want anyone to know even the names
of the churches you know cross point or
new horizons or something do you know
why they choose names like that because
they don't want you to know at first
glance that it's a church they're
ashamed of it and so you hear you see
you see you see a church these days you
see what it looks like has a name like
New Horizons and you think well what is
that is that like a is that a rehab
center for wealthy drug offenders was it
what is it and even if you went inside
and listened to the sermon that's being
delivered you still probably wouldn't
know you still wouldn't be exactly sure
well maybe this is the motivational
speech they give during a rec time or
something and that's the way the modern
church experience is designed you know
the church that I attended as a child
was was new at the
time was newly built and it was really
fascinating to look at this church which
you'd still go and look at it still
stands because it's it seemed like it
was made in order to maximize ugliness
to the greatest possible degree now old
Catholic churches the way they were
built was if you go into a really old
church you'll notice this old Catholic
Church is that they were all built so
that everybody in the church including
the priests is faced to the tabernacle
in the cross everybody is faced that
direction like we're all looking to
Jesus we're not looking at each other
we're not looking at the guy up on up
there because it's not about him we're
all looking up you know beyond really
not and that's how churches were
designed back in the back in the old
days but a change was made in the design
of churches and Catholic churches all
churches where now it's all about the
guy on stage it's all about him and
we're all everything is about glorifying
him and the band and it's all about that
so this church you know back in when I
was a kid the way it was designed was
they'd put the tabernacle off to the
side there was very little artwork no
stained glass or anything and it was
centered so that everything was was was
directed right at the priest and then
behind him was this absolutely hideous
decorative organ structure like for its
you know if like a like a church organ
the the pipes of the organ but they
weren't even functional they're just
decorative and that's what was the the
focal point of the of the experience
it's like if you if you turn on Joel
Osteen sometime which I don't recommend
and what does he have up there onstage
with them it's like a tree or something
like that or a globe right just like
some mundane secular kind of vague
ambiguous thing like that's what that's
the focus that's what we're all looking
at
god forbid you have it you god forbid
you have a cross up or up there right we
wouldn't want that
now I have no problem with simple
churches I'm not saying that all
churches should be extravagant far from
it I really like the unassuming little
old church houses that you find when you
travel I do a lot of drive
across Pennsylvania Virginia New
Hampshire and if you go around there up
and down the eastern you know the East
Coast you're going to find a lot of
these little old church houses that were
built probably a hundred two hundred
years ago very simple very unassuming
but beautiful and there's a kind where
you walk in there's no air conditioning
the pews are super uncomfortable there's
no cry room for the fussy child there's
no bells and whistles at all sometimes
you'd be lucky if you even get a usual
you'll get a sound system but that's
pretty much it as far as modern
additions go and I like those churches
because there's a real unmistakable
charm there and a feeling of connection
to the past and to your own Christian
history that you feel and you experience
that you'll never experience in the
comfortable temperature-controlled
confines of elevation Church or a
Lakewood or one of their cousins so what
I'm saying is simple does not equate to
ugly mountains are simple oak trees are
simple infants are simple tiny
colonial-era churches are simple they're
all simple in different ways and they're
beautiful in different ways modern
churches are not simple and they're not
cheap but all the money and care and
complexity is devoted to keeping the
hearts and minds of the congregation
pointed towards earthly things and
especially as I said towards the guy up
on the pulpit or the stage I guess
delivering his vaguely theological
opinions and that's what it's really odd
so everyone is there they listen to the
guy's opinions and the band also because
well he wouldn't want any of the pesky
artwork or Beauty distracting from the
solemn business of listening to him
ramble on and that's the worst part
about the modern trend of intentionally
making our churches ugly is that it
cloaks itself in this guise of self
abdicating humility when really it's
exactly the opposite Michelangelo showed
humility when he spent four years on his
back painting the story of the Bible on
the ceiling of the Sistine Chapel no
that's humility modern churches show
extraordinary self conceit and arrogance
when they expend their energy building
elaborate but hideous sets for their
band and their pasture to occupy that's
not humility why is it you know if if
one of these modernist behemoth churches
were to burn to the ground as long as
nobody was inside the building there
aren't going to be any weeping throngs
out in the street mourning it no one's
really gonna care the insurance the
insurance companies will handle it and a
few days later no one's gonna even
remember what that big dumb ugly thing
even look like people wept over Notre
Dame because of the beauty they wept out
they wept over it for the same reason
that a patriotic American would weep if
and I say as a Baltimore native Fort
McHenry the fortress where the you know
the star-spangled banner is we're waving
that inspired the national anthem that
Francis Scott Key wrote during the War
of 1812 as he looked at Fort McHenry and
the flags waving there now if Fort
McHenry which still stands on the harbor
in Baltimore if that burned to the
ground you know as a as a patriot and a
Baltimore David native I would probably
cry over that I would be really upset
why is it not because I idolized the
structure but because I revere what it
represents and what its presence and its
history brings to mind and that's why
the beauty of a church is so important
and that's why the the ugliness of
modern churches is such a tragedy and
it's why I really hope that the events
of this week and what happened a Notre
Dame might inspire us to once again
reach for the artistic heights that our
ancestors sought and attained now I want
to head a few things off at the pass
here because I wrote I wrote a piece on
this subject and so for the last few
hours especially while I was on the
plane because I don't have anything
better to do honestly I've been fielding
responses from Christians who really
appear to be arguing for ugliness like
they're arguing in principle for
ugliness so my my radical suggestion
that we should make beautiful churches
there are a lot of Christians who are
they're against it they say no I don't
want beautiful churches that's a
terrible thing I have no interest in
that it's such a perv
first mindset eye candy I just I cannot
comprehend it it's really amazing and
there are objections that I've seen arm
there are a few objections first of all
a few that I've already covered they say
well we don't want beautiful churches
because we're spending the money
elsewhere that's just that's that's
bogus I'm sorry that's not true it's not
a valid objection because the ugly
churches I'm targeting costs money all
churches cost money if you're gonna have
a place to congregate it's gonna cost
you money to build and a lot of these
modern ones cost a lot of money tens and
tens of millions of dollars we could
spend a lot less than that and still
make beautiful churches it in principle
doesn't cost anything beauty in
principle does not have any object or
any inherent cost now you do have to pay
someone the an artist or something so it
will cost you some good there's no
reason why it needs to cost a certain
amount so and then they'll say well it's
better to have simple churches again
simplicity and beauty can go
hand-in-hand so that's not a response to
my point at all and then they say and I
saw a lot of this that well the the
buildings mean nothing they have no
value physical beauty has no value it
doesn't matter at all in fact I saw
someone say exactly those words that the
buildings mean nothing they have no
meaning now this attitude is called
Gnosticism this is not really Christian
attitude
this is Gnostic the Gnostics believed
that all physical beauty and all
material existence in general is
entirely vain and worthless and even
evil
that's what Gnostics believed but
Gnostics Gnosticism is a heresy and it's
been long repudiated by Orthodox
Christianity the true Christian
understanding and the more thoughtful
sort of philosophically grounded
understanding is that beauty is
meaningful okay so to say that it means
nothing now I'm not saying it's the most
important thing but to look at a
building like the Notre Dame's that
means nothing that is not only is that a
Gnostic point of view but it's just a
it's in its unhuman you can't actually
feel it means nothing really has no
value
there imagine living a life with no
beauty at all if you really think that
physical beauty means nothing has no
value means nothing at all okay well
imagine living with no beauty imagine
living in just a totally bland room and
a bland landscape and there's no beauty
to speak of anywhere just dreary mundane
ugliness everywhere and that's some of
us you know almost do live in a
situation like that but imagine you had
no access to physical beauty whatsoever
you would want to kill yourself after a
while I mean you you literally would not
want to continue living because life
would be so bleak and despair inducing
your existence would just be would be
would be so so dreary that you wouldn't
even want to live so beauty is an
essential need an essential human need
it's not nothing and the other objection
I've heard is that well beauty is
subjective so who am I to call any
church ugly right how can I say that
well again here we've got an attitude
that is incompatible with Orthodox
Christianity and one that displays a
deep philosophical ignorant sand and
this is why you know what I noticed more
and more when in talking to Christians
is that there really is you know
obviously churches are not instilling
any kind of philosophical foundation in
their congregations whatsoever because
this is just a point of beauty is
subjective you tease in the eye of the
beholder this is the kind of modernist
tripe that Christians have rejected for
centuries and Allison you have all these
Christians saying it not realizing that
they can't say that as a Christian it's
completely incompatible with your faith
just think about it for two seconds and
it's not a coincidence that every person
on the planet that you meet barring the
insane people will say that a mountain
range is more beautiful than a puddle of
slush on the side of the road after a
snowstorm and they'll say the Sistine
Chapel is more beautiful than a bag of
your dog's fecal matter everyone arrives
at that conclusion not by coincidence
but by
our inherent recognition of something
objective in beauty now I say that it's
incompatible with Christianity because
God is the source of all beauty that's
the Christian understanding God is the
standard of beauty God therefore if you
believe in the Christian God you really
can't believe that beauty is subjective
now there is a subjective element in how
we perceive it and how it speaks to us
so there are certain things that I can
recognize as objectively beautiful yet
they just don't do it for me quite as
much as something else like I can listen
to you know a symphony and recognize it
this is beautiful music
however it's not something that I would
sit and listen to for very long but it
is beautiful I recognize that now if I
were to listen to Mozart or something
and say oh this is disgust
you disgust if I were to vomit at the at
the sound of Mozart well that that shows
that there's something disordered about
me it does I don't have to love it I
don't have to doesn't have to be my
favorite thing but I should be able to
perceive that it is beautiful and so we
all have our own tastes and we all have
you know some people you know love a
beach more than a mountain range you get
more of an emotional experience looking
at the ocean than you do mountains and
you know everyone is different in that
way but even if you're that way you're
not going to be grossed out by a
mountain range right you're going to
you're going to acknowledge and see that
it is something beautiful even if it
just doesn't connect with you on the
same level so that's the subjective
element in perception but beauty itself
is about it's about the in something
inherent in the thing that we're talking
about beauty is is an objective quality
in a thing
finally I'm told that well it's idol
worship to have beautiful churches with
with statues and so on and this is just
silly do you think that I mean idol
worship you think anyone worshipped the
Notre Dame
Cathedral as a god do you think anyone
was tempted to literally worship the
building as a god or when someone looks
at the Pieta or you know a great
sculpture by one of the Renaissance
artists you think anyone is tempted to
worship it like they think that it that
the thing itself is God now maybe the
pagans were but that's not a temptation
that you and I have when you look at a
at a beautiful ocean panoramic are you
tempted to start worshipping Poseidon no
you just you notice that it's beautiful
you love looking at it it brings your
mind to God to the God the real God the
same with beauty in a church and
Christian symbolism in a church now
here's what really gets me these
Christians who get all weirded out by
statues or stained glass or whatever who
can't apparently can't see the symbolic
significance of it these are the same
ones who would have a heart attack if
they caught you not standing in front of
the flag for the for the Pledge of
Allegiance if they you don't have your
hand in your heart you're standing if
you if you're kneel or you sit these are
these are the same ones I'm gonna
practically have a you know have a
seizure from seeing you do that and God
forbid if you were to burn a flag in
front of them they would call for the
death penalty for you so they see the
value in secular symbols in American
symbols and they don't consider that to
be idol worship Oh a flag touches the
ground it's you know it's it's blasphemy
so that's not idol worship and I'm not
I'm not saying that it is but I don't
know how you could say that that's not
idol worship but having a beautiful
church and a statue is so secular
symbols are okay but Christian symbols
aren't symbols that bring your mind to
America are fine but symbols that bring
your mind to God are not fine I just I
can't understand that mentality makes no
sense it's an irrational mentality it
just is and if anything is idol worship
in those scenarios it's got to be the
flag thing and again I don't think that
is but if one of those is it's the flag
one okay but if you're if you're able to
see that a flag yes it is in a
utilitarian materialistic sense it's
just a bit just a cloth right it's all
it is but if you're able to see
yeah I mean physically that's what it is
but it stands it represents it brings to
mind something greater than that well if
you can see that with the flag why can't
you see it with art and and churches and
stained-glass statues why can't you see
it there I just I don't get it all right
couple other things I wanted to mention
one other quick note related to the
Notre Dame burning listen you know I'm a
big critic of ilhan Omar the freshman
Democratic Representative I'm a critic
of hers I don't I don't like her iiiiii
and I I don't agree with pretty much
anything she stands for but she sent out
a tweet yesterday about Notre Dame
burning and I'll read what the tweet
said she said art and architecture have
a unique ability to help us connect
across our differences and bring people
together in important ways thinking of
the people of Paris and praying for
every first responder trying to save
this wonder okay that was her tweet
biljana mark it's fine
right it's fine as the two sentences
it's it's basically in line with what
every other politician said about it on
both sides of the spectrum it's in line
with what a lot of people said with
things that I said on Twitter yesterday
it's fine but of course we live in a
culture now where on both sides of the
spectrum we're constantly looking if
there's someone we disagree with and who
we think is usually wrong and Omar is
usually wrong well we're it's like we're
incapable of any kind of keeping things
in perspective right so if we think
she's usually wrong then that means that
she has to be wrong about literally
everything she says there has to be
something wrong with everything she
every word she speaks every public
statement she makes there has to be
something wrong with all of it and so we
start picking apart every little thing
to find things to complain about and
that's what people did with this tweet
they said well how art and architecture
it's a church why did you call it a
church you didn't say anything about
Jesus or Christ or God come on guys come
on
if Donald Trump or Ted Cruz or whoever
Republican had sent that exact same
tweet no conservative would be
criticizing it and nobody would there's
nothing where it's fine we don't need to
look for something to complain about
with every little thing that a person we
disagree with says now the reason why
she didn't offer up a prayer to Christ
is because she's Muslim and so that's
why she's not talking about Jesus Christ
and yet she didn't call it a church but
we all know that it's a church so I
don't think we need her to tell us that
maybe she was assuming that we already
know it's a church and so you don't need
to be reminded do you actually need her
to say PS by the way I am referring to
the church notre-dame Cathedral you know
what she means I just that's my response
to because I get the same treatment from
the other side a lot of the times or
I'll say something and maybe it's
clumsily worded maybe it isn't but
people are looking for a reason to
pounce and my response a lot of the
times is look you know what I meant
just back off calm down you know what
I'm trying to say so stop pretending
that you don't all right
let's see I had a bunch of emails well I
mentioned okay I guess I'll go to I go
to emails now Matt well show at
gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com so
I talked briefly yesterday about people
who worship their dogs now that is a
form of idol worship that really does
happen in the United States and my whole
point that I made yesterday on the show
well if you didn't see it was I wasn't
insulting dogs or anything like that I
just said dogs aren't people people are
more important you shouldn't love dogs
more than people that was that was my
whole point and as you might expect of
course got some responses I mean let me
just I'll read one response said C's
dear Matt I have always respected you
but there's something wrong with people
who don't like dogs I have no problem
admitting I prefer dogs to people a dog
has never lied to me or cheated me or
believed me dogs are the perfect example
of unconditional love I feel sorry for
you that you don't understand that or
see it yes I got a lot of stuff like
that first of all your dog never lied to
you because it has
vocal cords he's incapable of speech so
that's why he's never told you a lie but
the other reason why he doesn't do those
bad things it's because he's not capable
of making moral choices okay so when you
say well dogs never hurt my feelings
yeah but that's because dogs are not
capable of it
they're intrinsically incapable of
making moral choices it's not like every
dog in the world can make a moral choice
and just always makes the right one so
that dogs are these engine gellick as
saintly beings who are perfectly
virtuous no that's not the case
they don't assess things on them on a
moral landscape they don't have access
to that sort of thought process so
that's why they don't do those things
what why is it now there are dogs who
hurt people at dogs mall people to death
dogs can rip up your furniture dogs can
poop on your rug but why is why don't we
hold dogs legally responsible when they
do those things and why is it absurd to
get angry at a dog even if he does chew
up your carpet why is that because he
know what he was doing that's the whole
reason but if you're going to ascribe
virtuous motivations to dogs if you're
going to actually claim that dogs are
capable of real courage and real
self-sacrificing love and and real
virtue then you then you would have to
say that the dogs who do bad things are
actually evil and should be good should
go to prison should they should be they
should face legal penalties it doesn't
make any sense to say oh yeah well
they're capable yeah whenever they do
something that appears to be good well
that's a virtuous choice they made as
dogs but if they do something bad now
it's not their fault they're just dogs
you see that this again it's irrational
doesn't doesn't make any sense you've
got to have one view of dogs here it
can't be it can't be both either they
make moral choices are they don't and
the answer is they don't
which is why you can't really give them
credit for not doing mean things that
people do and in fact yes there are
people who do terrible things
that's true but every time that a person
has acted kindly towards you
person has told you the truth a person
has been loyal to you a person has
comforted you anytime a person has done
something good for you and I guarantee
that many people have done good things
for you whoever you are in your life
those are those acts of goodness and
virtue are far more me infinitely more
meaningful than anything that any dog
has ever done because those people that
did those good things they could they
made a choice they they knew they had
two options and they knew this they
understood and comprehended the
sacrifice they were making in paying you
that kindness and yet they did it anyway
and so it is so much more meaningful
yeah people are more complicated because
they make choices and they might hurt
you and they might do bad things just
like you do bad things by the way if you
say that you like people more than dogs
are better the people you're saying that
you think dogs are better than you to
that you are worse than a dog and maybe
that's all you're really saying I think
maybe it's just a reflection of your
opinion of yourself but regardless
that's just that's so it's great that
dogs don't hurt your feelings but you
know a doorknob won't hurt your feelings
either a tree will never rob a bank okay
an aunt will never bully a kid on a
school bus okay so the color blue will
never do anything bad to you because all
of these things are incapable of moral
evil all right let's see this is from
the beardo kradic fascist
greetings mat of the waltz just want to
know your thoughts on teen beards
I know beards are great but teen beards
look like someone cut the bristles off a
toothbrush and glued them onto a bloody
face so what should I tell my young
friends I know it's harsh but I think
they might have - dare I say shave well
you are no bearded kradic fascist if you
would ever tell anyone to shave man or
woman okay child or adult listen yeah
teenage beards are not aesthetically
pleasing but but you know you need to
experiment with your facial hair and we
all went through awkward phases with our
facial hair you experiment you figure
out what works for you but to ever
discourage anyone from
expressing their themselves through
facial hair I think is just it is an
abomination and how dare you this is
from Miriam says huge fan of the podcast
on Monday you were talking about the
alcohol debate in the church and you
kept saying miracle it is pronounced
miracle
it hurts my brain to hear you say it
wrong my name is Miriam meaning that
people replaced the eye with an A all
the time it brings forth a certain anger
in me that is only remedied by throwing
my phone out the window please stop
abusing the word miracle or I might have
to go to therapy well well Miriam I who
what who are you to say okay it's in the
eye of the beholder here if I want to
say miracle I'm gonna say miracle Miriam
how are you supposed to say miracle is
that what people say I don't know it
must be a Baltimore thing I don't know
miracle miracle miracle miracle it's a
miracle
you know now I've forgotten how to say
the word because of you Miriam let's see
here
got one more we'll go to Christy says
Matt I appreciate your thoughtful
perspectives on a variety of issues
including theology I was genuinely
shocked genuinely that's another one you
could get on me for pronouncing
strangely I was genuinely shocked when
you said that the rapture is a new
teaching that didn't exist for thousands
of years after Christ I had no idea
that's something I've always assumed was
a universally Christian doctrine I have
been taught from childhood is even
debated and I was intrigued to hear why
you didn't believe it was actually a
thing I was disappointed when you said
that the only verse rapture believing
people used to support their belief are
the Matthew verses I had literally just
read Luke 17 of my kids that morning
which says when the Son of Man returns
it will be like it was in Noah's day in
these days
the people enjoy banquets and parties
and wedding night right up to the time
Noah entered his boat and the flood came
and destroyed them all and the world
would be as it was in the days of lot
people went about their daily business
eating and drinking buying and selling
farming and building until the morning
lot left Sodom then fire and burning
sulfur rained down from heaven
and destroyed them all yes it will be
business as usual right up to the day
when the Son of Man revealed is revealed
on that day a person out on the deck of
a roof must go down into the house to
pack a person out in the field must not
return home remember what happened to
Lot's wife if you cling to your life you
will lose it and if you let your life go
you will save it that night two people
will be asleep in one bed one will be
taken the other left two women will be
grinding flour together at the middle
one will be taken the other left end of
Bible verse these verses sure make it
sound like Jesus is coming as taking is
something to watch for and we are the
ones who will be taken other verses of
warning to be alert and watchful also
come right to mind without even
searching the verses about the
bridesmaids whose lamps are empty when
the bridegroom comes I've always assumed
those verses referred to being watchful
and ready for the coming of Christ also
the verses I've always read as an actual
description of the rapture quote the
Trump shall sound the trumpet shall
sound and the dead in Christ will first
rise would you mind giving this topic a
little more thorough treatment it felt
like you set up a straw man when you
said the Matthew verses are the ones
only ever used to defend the idea of a
rapture okay so I don't think that the
Matthew verse I don't think I said the
Matthew verse is the only one used I
think I said it's one of the main ones
used and in fact you you use that same
one you used Luke's version of the
Matthew verse but it's the same verse
just you're getting it for Tudor four
Gospels it's the same same thing phrased
a little bit differently so that's the
first thing also I don't I'm not sure
what translation you were giving me
there but yeah this is a translation it
uses phrases like business as usual
which is certainly not phrase that
existed in the first century so I'm not
sure what translation you use there
might be a translation problem here as
well what I'll say again is that I think
the verse that you quoted there at
length clearly refers to the wicked
people being taken it does not refer to
the good people being taken this is
about the damnation of the wicked so
when the Son of Man returns it will be
like it was in Noah's day
and then it goes on from there so in
those day the people who are taken taken
from the earth through the form of a
flood where the wicked ones so I think
that's the point in that verse what I'll
say about some of the other ones you
mentioned there's one there's one you
even mention I think it's in
Thessalonians that talks about you know
the righteous ascending and meeting
Christ in the clouds but you didn't even
mention that well I'll give you that one
maybe maybe that's probably your best
one to pull from but there again now I
just think that yes now when you're
proof texting when you're when you're
looking for a verse that matches a
theological point of view that you
already held before even looking at the
Bible you're gonna be able to find a
verse that will support it and that's
the problem with proof texting and
looking at things out of context which I
think the rapture is pulled out of
context so yes that particular version
in Thessalonians that would match up
with the rapture but it's just you
cannot hang this entire idea of the
rapture on that one little verse and
that's just that's an invalid way of
looking at the Bible in general and
something else I'll keep in mind here is
that the maybe it seems like semantics
but it's really not God we know that
heaven does not literally exist in the
clouds right we know that I mean
children might think of it that way but
we know that if you go up you're gonna
find clouds and you're gonna eventually
leave the atmosphere you'll be in outer
space heaven is not literally physically
located above us when we speak about God
above and when we look up to pray and
all that kind of stuff that's
metaphorical language so now maybe
there'll be people meeting Jesus in the
clouds at the end of time but that's not
really
Jesus what really even would be the
point of that because heaven is not
actually literally in the klutzo what
I'm saying is I would see that as
metaphorical language the same way when
Jesus talks about God above and God
being above us and in the heavens and so
on which Jesus does talk about we take
that metaphorically because we know that
he doesn't he's that literally up
sitting in a cloud right
now you could say well Jesus ascended
into heaven and we are led to believe by
scripture that there was a physical
ascension like he actually rose above
the people who were witnessing it and
yes but again there it's not like Jesus
had to physically go up to get into
heaven so if he physically ascended in
front of the the people who witnessed it
then I would say I would think that that
was for their benefit you know because
of the the the symbolic significance of
going up above in a spiritual sense it
wasn't something that he didn't have to
go that direction to get to heaven it
was just something for the benefit of
the rest of us we could talk about the
ascension and it makes it that makes a
lot more sense to us just sort of
intuitively than God I don't know how I
don't know how she would refer to it if
God just were to or if Jesus were to
just vanish into another realm into
another into into you know heaven how
would we even refer to that how would we
intuitively conceive of it so that's
what the Ascension is for but at the end
of time I'm not really sure what the
point of those theatrics would be maybe
that's how it will be I don't know but
what I'm saying is the overall doctrine
of the rapture is a modern inventions
from the 19th century and for centuries
Christians read those verses and they
had no concept of the rapture as we know
it today
now just because it's modern doesn't
necessarily make it wrong but it should
make you pretty suspicious of it why is
it that every Christian before that
point read the Bible and never noticed
that and now all the sudden we do is it
because we have some sort of new insight
that's new to us that the Holy Spirit
kept hidden from Christians for 18 19th
centuries or is it because we've just
come up with a new theological concept
and we're looking for justification in
the Bible I think it's probably more of
the latter
but that's my opinion all right we'll
leave it there thanks everybody for
watching thanks for listening Godspeed
everyone its Andrew Clavin host of the
Andrew Clavin show notre-dame Cathedral
in Paris burns and no one wants to
mention the spate of church desecrations
and arson fires that's been sweeping
through France all through Lent we'll
talk about it on the Andrew Clavin show
I'm Andrew Clavin